so I'm a physician a nutritionist and a
trained chef if you want people to eat
healthy food it has to taste good has to
meet their palate needs so when you're
looking at I'm trying to find out
specific foods that are nutrient rich
that you might enjoy so what will it
take to get me to get you to eat food
more often it's about finding what you
enjoy with taste delicious it's easy to
prepare you can find the ingredients in
a local grocery store I mean essentially
that's why I went back to the Four
Seasons and did a chef internship I
wanted to make it easy and fun for you
to add healthy food so for me when I
think of adding food and we're gonna add
number one fiber not in breakfast cereal
I think of flour and sugar and the same
thing so I'm looking at adding fiber as
in vegetable fruit beans and nuts and
getting 30 grams a day and it's pretty
easy to do if you actually show people
how the biggest bang we're gonna get for
any effort the return on lowering health
care costs on better brain performance
on less sick days is adding fiber so it
should and is number one but most people
don't emphasize it number two is about
lean and clean protein weight maybe
people eat junk it's mean protein it's
anything but lean and clean so lean and
clean like wild seafood free-range
organic poultry if you're eating a steak
it should be grass-fed organic I mean
some things are simple but people don't
get that their protein is hormone and
pesticide enriched and it makes them
sick and then three is healthy fat
certainly not a low fat diet it's about
adding healthy fat so using more of you
know olive oil of course hello
and then nuts and avocados and seafood
those are healthy fats and we need more
of them and I like people to cook with
Ned oils as well so avocado oil nut oil
and olive oil those are the oils I have
people cook with so when I give them
those in their food tastes great it's
easy
the fourth food is beneficial beverages
you have to be really specific about
what you drink
of people who were really overweight
have major health problems they get 20
to 35% of their calories from what they
drink that's that is it just makes no
sense but they're caught up in these
super sugary drinks so more water yes
you can have a couple two of coffee it's
great for your health but limited at
that green teas fabulous I love to start
the day with the protein smoothie I want
to transform America with a protein
smoothie in the morning you know easy
two minutes
um you add scoop of protein almond milk
one cup of berries a little shot of like
chia seed it's two minutes you're done
you're out the door it's awesome you
feel great it's improves your job and
brain performance all day and the fifth
group here's a surprise fabulous flavors
your food has to taste awesome or you're
not going to eat it so we need more
flavor if we're going to change the way
Americans eat and here's the thing your
brain is biochemically attractive flavor
so Italian spices curry spices chili
spices they taste good they smell good
because we have a bio chemical affinity
slow aging they decrease inflammation
they raise your metabolism for weight
loss and then don't forget you have to
have dark chocolate every day it's in
critical component they have one ounce
28 grams of 70% cocoa when I say dark
we're not talking milk chocolate when I
give those people those five foods it
makes it easy to add them we have
enormous success in transforming eating
with foods they can you know I helped
them pick of these which foods do you
love that you could eat more of well
that's an easy sell
you